police fired tear gas at protesters but
it didn't stop them from marching in
their thousands towards Congress in
Honduran capital Tegucigalpa they
accused President Juan Orlando Hernandez
of corruption are demanding his
resignation the president denies the
corruption claims several people were
injured in the protest organized by a
coalition of trade union and public
workers some businesses were set on fire
the people want this narco dictator out
of the presidency we don't want him
can't they understand it out with one
Orlando Hernandez is the only slogan I
can tell you out with him we're sick of
this Honduras we have nothing to eat at
home - all Honduras mobilized throughout
the country so that the government feels
the pressure for that man to get out of
power last week US federal prosecutors
accuse Hernandez of receiving 1.5
million dollars from illegal drug
traffickers in exchange for protection
and funding his election campaign in
2013 these accusations are categorically
false and perverse made up by a drug
trafficker called Alexander Arden they
want revenge against the only president
who's done what he's needed to do
they're trying to stop us in our fight
against drug trafficking but we're not
going to stop the conservative leader
has enjoyed a good relationship with the
US government Donald Trump backed him in
the disputed 2017 re-election and has
applauded him for stemming the flow of
migrants and illegal drugs to the US but
the opposition disagrees he was a
nobodies we live in a country that is a
narco-state with the supreme court of
justice the public ministry Congress and
the armed forces are used for drugs to
cross the border drugs have been
crossing through Honduras since 2002 17
years of it 17 years of money being
handed to politicians
the drugs war means Honduras has one of
the highest murder rates in the world
are the crimes coupled with poverty and
corruption is driving the need to escape
hundreds of Hondurans attempt to migrate
to the United States every day Sara hire
at Al Jazeera